hey sluggies I cannot believe I'm saying
this but trash Tuesday will be at the
Regent Theater in LA August 4th please
go get your tickets now I can't wait to
meet every single one of our slugs I'm
really excited it's going to be a great
show it's gonna be interactive we're
gonna play games it's just gonna be an
amazing night so it's gonna be so fun
there's gonna be games laughter swimming
dancing new merch yeah we have a lot
planned and it's a little scary for me
but we're going to be doing a lot of
audience interaction we're going to be
doing Q a
um we have games that we're going to be
playing and there'll also be just like a
live podcast element we have a lot of
stuff planned it's going to be really
fun and also there's a little bit of a
roasting
section you'll have to wait and see
um but I love you guys and I can't wait
to see you this Friday at the Regent
Theater in Los Angeles
[Music]
you guys a trash Tuesday we love liquid
death and our listeners get 20 off their
first liquid death apparel purchase this
is an offer that is available
exclusively at liquiddeath.com trash
exclusions May apply that's
liquiddeath.com
trash for a limited time nutriple is
offering our listeners ten dollars off
their first month subscription and free
shipping when you go to nutribull.com
and enter the promo code trash find out
why over 3 500 Health Care Professionals
recommend neutriful for healthier hair
neutrophone.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash
that's neutriful.com promo code trash hi
slugs happy August I am on tour and I'm
going to be an Oxnard August 27th and uh
then I'll be in DC Boston Wisconsin San
Diego Chicago Detroit San Jose and
Irvine get tickets at astronice.com mwah
hello sluggies we had such a fun time
today I am so excited to be out on the
road doing the welcome to anniewood tour
you can actually see me tonight I have a
Annie and friends show at The Comedy
Store in the main room it's probably
sold out
um you also can see me in Philadelphia
August 11th and 12th I'll be in Calgary
at that Great Outdoors Comedy Festival
August 27th I'll be in San Francisco
Austin
um La Jolla
a bunch of other places just go to
annieleterman.com shows and you can see
me every Thursday on Annie wood
foreign
I just bought like a suction cup thing
for cellulite we'll see if it helps oh
wait does it work cupping thing would I
ask you a question have you done the
other thing
um yeah I did but it's like it's
expensive and you have to do it so
consistently that my schedule I was like
I can't what is it just like a really
deep basically all of the things it's
breaking up like I don't know exactly
what it's breaking up but it's it's like
suctioning your it's like you know like
the cups you like Chinese medicine cups
yeah if you ran them across her leg and
then the endermology
um machine yeah it's like a suction and
you put this like really kind of hot
Gauzy thing on I don't know why it is so
attractive it looks like do you have any
pictures of the internet I sure do
um it was like an accidental thirst trap
I was like oh I didn't realize I was
gonna look so hot in this cool bandage
it kind of makes me like get why guys
always hit on you when you're injured
I'm like okay wait a second you're
involved they bandage you up it looks
like a bandage it's like a it's like a
white sock that you put on basically oh
I've worn one of those before but since
when do guys hit on you when you're
injured I know guys I've never hit on
you no no I always haven't had that
experience where it's like if I get a
broken leg or broken foot it's like
they come out what is that wounded bird
she can't defend herself or Run Away by
the way I honestly because at first I
was like this is so sweet that won't
help me but then there was no actual
help it was just kind of hanging around
being really slow about driving me home
I remember my friend Chris I broke my
foot I can't believe I must have pulled
this on him before I broke my foot
peeing in the woods once no you have
definitely have not okay I was in uh how
do I know you that is the weirdest story
ever like we should never have met
someone was in the woods doing something
active enough that they might have
broken their phone yeah that's so
dangerous no I was um I went to Pecos I
was living in New Mexico I was living in
Santa Fe we went to Pecos to this like
cabin my ex-boyfriend was there with
like his what if his family I don't know
why I was there but it was his
ex-boyfriend we weren't together anymore
but we were just friends it was my
ex-boyfriend his friend Chris and
someone's parents so you were on a trip
with your ex-boyfriend and you don't
know why I don't know why I was that it
was like yeah I don't know who invited
me why I was I'm sure I was like no one
I had to get there though because it was
just one truck I don't know why we can
relate to this though I'm going on a
trip with my ex next week and I don't
know why yeah it's just sort of like
we like each other we like each other
yeah we like each other yeah it doesn't
make sense but it does you know I I got
I it got weird though because okay so
then we were leaving and this was my
like this was an X that I held very like
special to my heart for so long and I
finally had to just like
I had to just like
slice them up ahead of him kill him in
my like I had to just stop giving a [__]
about him because it was like why am I
still focused on this person I would
always go back to him or whatever can I
live in the woods what what did was
there a murder in the woods oh wait yeah
he's alive he's probably well I don't
know I don't talk to him too much
anymore why
why am I keeping you why do you think
you were so hooked on him that you had
to like you know kill him in your mind
because I do is it I had this theory
that like if we are so obsessed with
someone it's because like they were
rejecting of you and that like it was
like the slot machine thing where
sometimes they liked you and sometimes
they didn't was it that or do you feel
like you have a different reason why
um I think we had like a really weirdly
romantic kind of
crazy story of how we met and he also
was like the first person I dated after
that stuff happened to me in high school
oh and he was just really
um he's very annoying and there's always
a woman next to him very angry at him
but even though he is that type of
annoying dude he is very sweet and he
was very loving to me and very like so
it was almost sounds like he was there
for you he was like the only guy I had
dated who was really like encouraging my
art and like there was just like things
on me I really liked
he made me feel really beautiful really
really loved like all these things and
he was very like that patient is
intoxicated yeah I know that is one of
the reasons why like the one of the last
guys that I recently dated I could not
break it off no matter how hard I tried
because he really did make me feel so
pretty like no matter how much like if I
had gained weight or whatever it just
were these monsters making her feel ugly
we should have them on but the reason
that it ended was because he was just a
little too possessive like jealousy
there were things there I was like okay
like long term I don't think this is
gonna work because like if we're not
even official and this is happening like
I can only imagine what it's going to be
feeling suffocated in any way or watched
it's just like for me it's just like
monitored some people might find that
hot like maybe if they've had a
different history with men where they
weren't like that but for me I feel so
it was like the guy I told you where he
like didn't want me to smoke cigarettes
which is like a normal thing but for
some reason the way he said it it made
me smoke so many cigarettes I was like a
lung cancer at you [__] you know like I
just was like but I think with um with
my ex and Santa Fe
yeah I was very young when I met him and
then I never really like
um found that sort of like loving
consistency from a guy for a while so I
think I kept going back to him and
idolizing that sort of way he made me
feel and obviously like we were like I
think I was 18 when I dated him or
something so we were really young so it
wasn't like we were gonna but it was
really we just had like he had he was
from this place in Vermont where
my mom's best friend is from from high
school
and
um his his when I'm well I guess
actually let me back this up a little
bit so when we were driving to Santa Fe
to look to move me to Santa Fe my
parents and I took an RV and drove all
my stuff out and we stopped at this
um
I think I told the story
I don't think so I'd never I don't
remember you breaking anything in the
woods this is so I know I've gone way
back but anyway I'll just go fast
um I don't need to romanticize too long
about ex-boyfriends but uh because
you're gonna make me fall in love I
might try and find him
I'm sure you can take him from whoever's
very mad standing next time just looking
at him like [__] [__] but um no so
he he just has a very weird name and my
mom was like we were like joking about
when I went to Santa Fe I was wearing
this like engagement ring that was my
mom had found in her purse that was like
she had taken out of a safety deposit
box I was like my grandmother's or
something and I was just wearing it and
my mom like spun this tail this like
joke about how I was going to meet this
guy and she just picked the craziest
name I'm just I'm releasing this man so
I'm not gonna say his name it's such a
weird name I just don't want him to need
to be attached to me ever again this
poor guy he gave me a good 20 years of
this so but um she was so my mom was
like you're gonna meet this and she just
made up the most ridiculous name you
could even imagine
and my first party in Santa Fe this guy
was like Hey I'm and it was that name
are you serious like it was really weird
and this is the guy yeah and I was like
oh my God and I like pulled him aside I
was like my mom like this whole thing
just happened like we're engaged like
and it was this joke and then when he
tells the story and like that's where I
like get like a little bit like because
he would always tell the story and he'd
be like all right so we're at this party
and all there's like just the circle of
guys and then it like parts and just
this like hot girl just being so funny
and so cool and like I just pushed my
way through and I'm like who are you and
I tell her my name and she's like we're
engaged and so I was like always like
cute the way he was okay what you're
describing I describing is
basically super dangerous because if
you're meat cute with somebody is that
good up front it even no matter what
they're like after that point you're
gonna keep coming back but that's
becoming more romanticizing that because
it was such a good story you know like
the story was I have been there I have
been there I hung on way too long with a
guy because I just thought that our
story was so like picture perfect why do
our brains do this to us because we
watch like movies when we were little
and it's you know like you think don't
you remember like being and I remember
being in elementary school and be like I
can't wait to be like a teenager and
have a boyfriend like you just didn't
even know what it is you know yeah so
how you meet someone really sort of like
um dictates how long what you're willing
to put up with that relationship because
like imagine meeting a guy in a very
boring way
um it's easier to let it go yeah you're
like how do you mean I don't even
remember how we met how did we like you
know what I mean like but that's why I
think there's this term term like I
learned not that long ago it's called
limerence and it's that that pure
obsessive feeling for somebody and I
think a lot of when I felt that in the
past for somebody it's because the
beginning was just so Picture Perfect
Right and limerence in is supposed to
kind of be not a good thing right it's
like you're in a state of crush
Obsession yeah fantasy yeah I definitely
don't I mean I I think it's cute and I'm
like I definitely like love the person I
was that that felt love for this person
but I definitely don't I I grew out of
it and I and I look back and I go like
oh God I like I mean this guy really I I
yanked him back in a couple times he's
like what are you he's like I'm back
here again like you'd be like oh my God
I can really relate to this I have
definitely done this because I I just
was so fixated on the beginning but
having to break
more okay so then okay so this was the
guy right also by the way so his
his ma or my mom's friend from this gets
crazier so that we meet that way we
start dating then his mom
uh we're talking to his parents or
whatever and we find out that my mom's
friend from from high school had been at
a bike race and her and her friend were
giving like Gatorade to the bikers and
an elderly woman put her car in Reverse
accidentally and ran them over [__]
killed my mom's friend's friend oh my
God friends pelvis was like crushed what
she's doing okay now my parents are
actually in Canada with them right now
they're on an island with this woman
right now but she she was really she was
in the hospital for like six months
and my ex-boyfriend's dad was a is a
famous or a successful sculptor and he
made the memorial for that woman who
passed away yeah and that's what we
found out like there was just like on
like there would just be like another
thing and another thing and I'd be like
oh I guess like the universe is like
we're like supposed to be together and
and um
that I would absolutely die if even one
of these coincidences happen with the
guy so I I just power to you for even
moving on in any capacity because I've
never had anything like he is so
annoying it's like he's actually some
but he became rejecting of me like later
on when I kept coming back in
and being like hey remember me we're
like supposed to be together or whatever
okay sorry keep going keep going no no
but like but it was like but I know what
you're but I I was hard I would hang so
hard on to those things but I I this is
like a whole like twin flame situation I
want to put a pin in it and definitely
talk about it after we get to the Bone
okay so so he wanted me to go somewhere
I always we were friends forever
whatever and he
um
we drove to Pecos we hung out with
whoever these elderly people were they
were not his parents I don't know who
they were they were probably my age now
but
um the people that seemed old and we're
driving back I think I had one beer I
wasn't drunk I wasn't High I was just
regular and I went we stopped to pee I
went into the woods I peed I didn't get
any splashback on me and I was so proud
of myself Miracle it isn't it it was a
miracle I was dry I dried out I just I
you know
I air dried I put my underwear on I
couldn't believe it I usually piss all
over myself when I try to be in the
woods and so I left like triumphantly
Out of the Woods like to these two guys
it's just Kristen and I don't say the
crazy name and I I leap out and I'm like
and um
I just fell right on my foot I just
broke the [__] out of my foot and I was
like you know like 20 feet from the car
I had to like Army roll or army crawl
back to the [__] I was so hurt and
then I get in I'm like sitting in
between them in this stupid truck and
and my friend Chris like does not want
to be a part of this like well quickly
guys are the worst if you're hurt around
guys they don't know what to do like
they're just like I'm so hard what do I
do
how do I drive and have this heart of a
bone it's easy to catch her she's Army
crawling it was like but so but
but um can we just bleep a name out okay
so I was like I just like it's so hard
no but that was the joke no parents just
made the name up oh
and your mom made that Nema yeah she was
like you're gonna be and this was like a
running bit the whole time we were
driving out
it was like crazy and then it was like
he was the second person I met at the
school I was like
and then him and these guys are like
fighting over me they're like as you
were crawling away
they were over me at this point but then
they got under me again if you ever
break a bone and you're in a truck with
two guys just take a gun out and kill
yourself because they are never gonna
help you no no they hurt themselves all
the time and they do nothing about it
you did help me but Chris was like Chris
was like you're fine literally you can
see like the bone is like it's so
swollen and you can just I know it's
broken I've broken this bone before I
was like it's broken we did go to the
hospital and Chris is like yeah you know
let's have a we have history so he's
like all right I better [__]
not have to deal with this [__] but so
we go to the hospital Chris leaves and
stayed with me for a really long time
but then so that subsequent
two months three months of this injury
I remember going they lived together and
going over there because it was taking
care of me for a while and then he was
like I can't I like no longer have the
capacity to do this to take care of you
I mean he was at the hospital then he
was like staying at my house and stuff
like sleeping over and it was just like
well yeah we weren't gonna like
what they're not going to take care of
you yeah he did as much as he could but
it's like are we gonna be like serious
boyfriend and girlfriend again it was
just sort of like it was like it was
like the role of like a husband who
sings that song Limit to Your Love but
wasn't he a team at this point this was
years later so we're probably like 24 or
something at this point 23. yeah
but I will tell you what he he did like
to play a lot play this with me too
because he would have a girlfriend and
his girlfriend would like go to the
bathroom or something and he would be
all talking to me or he'd be like I'd be
like um
jealous of some girl like I'd be like oh
how's your like girlfriend or whatever
maybe like it's not like how we were you
know like how we were oh yeah he kept
baiting you and for a while I mean when
I went back recently and he was like I
went back like four years ago and he was
like okay so I kind of want to talk
about this because I know that people
are really wrapped up in the whole idea
of a twin flame and are you familiar
with I think it's unhealthy yes I've
heard of it I've always wanted it I've
never okay I've been close to having it
I've been fully wrapped up maybe twin
flames is your guy's breath when it's
nice this could be right so twin flame
is the idea that someone there was once
upon a time one soul split in half oh my
God right so basically Esther there's
someone out there for you that is a
mirror to your soul it's a problem
[Laughter]
that I could literally be twin flames
with literally anyone I meet like I will
just find a way how did there different
ways you can figure out if someone is
your twin flame or not this is the
theory right one of it is like you can't
you can't stand them like you know
you're like is he still annoying because
maybe I twin flame though because they
basically
reflect a lot of who you are you're
almost the same Soul you're the same
thing so it's like that's annoying
usually when you're in a relationship
with them it's very tumultuous but I
wanted to talk about it because I was
listening to Dr Romney I listened to all
of her stuff about like narcissists and
whatnot right but she basically says a
lot of people who um subscribe to the
idea of like oh this person my partner
is my twin flame tend to have a
difficulty leaving narcissistic
relationships because they really
believe that they kind of like hang in
abusive relationships longer because
they subscribe to the idea that no this
is supposed to be hard because this is
my twin flame and I'm sticking to it
I've had one of those relationships I
feel like where it's like you're so like
there's such a connection
but see isn't that connection then like
something that we all think is this
special connection but it's actually
like like a toxic I'll give you an
example very very similar with Annie
where like there's almost so much like
random things that you're like wait like
what do you call it when something is
just so so much alignment in how things
happen for instance I met a boy right
he was pigeon told like me had the same
heart arrhythmia as me like everything
about him
we used to call each other like sibs it
was like him award when we were friends
it was like Hey Sim hey sib hey we were
that identical and we ended up we
started hooking up every sib hooks up
with you
it's a gateway drug for you to be
brother sister I know maybe he can do
that
um so identical like we were almost like
I looked at him and I'm like I hate him
so much because I think I like hate
myself and then we got into a very very
beautiful but often like toxic cycle of
like
[__] like I didn't like the way like
he would speak to me but I hung in there
because we really believed we were twin
flames yeah I hung in there and I'm like
why am I letting him talk to me this way
that's okay I I'm probably just I would
tell myself I probably need to hear it
and I probably just need to like
withstand all of this like the way he's
speaking to me
um because I I would like justify it in
my head and then I would show the text
messages to someone else and they'd be
like you need to block this person my uh
I had my phone like deleted all these
text messages from this one ex-boyfriend
not the one in Santa Fe that my like
crazy crazy
my most heated relationship I've ever
had but my phone just delete like I
think my phone was like we this we can't
have this apple was like we can't have
this it was wild or maybe he went back
when the unsend came he was like oh [__]
on send unscent he was like a poet it
was wild you can't date writers you
can't date people that are that good
because they will [__] hurt you in a
way that you have you are like I was
only like damn dude that was good
yeah
so there's this crazy beverage brand out
there called liquid death and it looks
just like beer you may have seen these
tall boy cans with skulls on them from
liquid death at festivals concerts bars
or maybe even on Zoom calls why is it
called liquid death because it's death
to plastic and it murders ear thirst
they make Mountain Water flavored
sparkling water and now they even have
iced tea which comes in three flavors
Grim leafer rest in Peach and armless
Palmer look liquid death is awesome it's
this new beverage out it looks like beer
I myself don't drink alcohol so I get to
have the cool feeling of cracking open a
cold one I feel like I fit in it fits
right in my hand like a berries too I
can even drive with it because it's just
water and I'm thirst quenched all of you
suckers might be hungover and tomorrow I
am going to be hydrated feeling good
thanks to liquid death you can find
liquid depths healthy beverages on
Amazon or at a retailer near you and
trash to say listeners get 20 off their
first liquid death apparel purchase
available exclusively at liquiddeath.com
trash exclusions May apply that's
liquiddeath.com trash are you tired of
dealing with thinning hair I know I am
when I got off birth control when I
turned 30 my hair started to just fall
off my head thankfully for neutrophil
I've been able to really see some great
improvements you guys I love hair and I
love having it and I love looking at it
and that's why I love neutral fall okay
because neutralfol is a gimmick it's not
a get rich quick scheme you take it and
you wait and you're patient and you get
results a lot of women are impacted by
thinning hair it don't you know there's
no need to be embarrassed or feel
ashamed neutral is a healthy happy safe
way to actually get your hair back the
right way take the first step to visibly
thicker healthier hair for a limited
time neutrophilus offering our listeners
10 off your first month's subscription
and free shipping when you go to
neutriful.com and enter the promo code
trash find out why over 3 500 Healthcare
professionals recommend neutrophil for
healthier hair neutrifold.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash
that's neutral.com promo code trash
I have been like trying to make Dave my
twin flame for 11 years and I've made
zero percent progress but like I'll try
to look like him oh the times I'm like
do you think we're soul mates he's like
there's no such thing as soulmate I love
Dave he's like but don't you think
that's important to have like because
you guys are alike and different I feel
like with Todd the reason Todd is like
my guy is because he is [__] calm
cool collected like my other boyfriends
that are like me that are like oh it's
the word you cannot no it's impossible
but Todd were alike and where sometimes
I'm cracking up because Todd will be
like screaming have you noticed how loud
Todd is Todd will be talking about like
screaming he's laughing he's louder than
ever at the party and I'm like it's just
so funny that I found another loudy just
together we're just the loudest people
that have ever existed me and Dave
together are just eating onions that's
what we do farting and eating
but yeah I like I
I'm now like how have I never had a twin
flame exchange is is it does it have
something to do with like because I
didn't have one early in life it doesn't
have to be a romantic partner it can be
someone you never get maybe it's
Christina I think right I think you're
very different I think it's I think it's
Rick
what the [__] that's gross you were but
maybe I think maybe definitely for a
period of time Benji and I were like had
a twin flame like a platonic twin flame
thing where it was like
dislike but also like so much fun
together so we were twin flames at one
point too yeah
like a friend thing for me I guess that
I just think that I yeah that there's
this one like like I I mean
I don't know I don't know how to say
this
it just is like I do feel like those
like fiery things are just like not
nothing I was so addicted they're
terrible I mean I found Todd in the
basement you know what I mean I was like
where's my mail but that's exactly it
I've learned in my 30s or even recently
single that like I really just want like
a quiet no fireworks Dr Drew told you
yes I'm like he's married yeah no but
it's so true where it's like I've always
dismissed that before as like oh he's
gonna bore me or but I'm like wait a
second like I don't bore me like guys
that were dating seemed like he was that
but then he came in with the like
anxious
attachment stuff like and by the way
he's like incredibly sweet and kind and
wonderful just like not a match for me
um because I am somebody who needs to be
allowed to like fly right like you
cannot try and tell me I can't do
certain things one might say swim
or Swim but back to limerence too like
this is a big thing I've been learning
because a lot of the young girlies on
Tick Tock talk about like how they're in
situationships and basically like
limerences at play there because
you get so addicted to the guy or the
girl whose only responsive like some of
the time and that is it just blows my
mind I'm like I wish I that's such a
life hack I wish I knew when I was in my
20s of like the guys do it to people
yeah yeah get them obsessed with you yes
thank you we have a trail of ducklings
behind you
oh
it's the only response you know every
other day or like that gets you're just
and they're not knowing you're like are
they doing this on purpose or are they
yeah and I by the way um that is like we
would never fall for that [__] no no
are you kidding he's been with me I've
fallen for that I I have two in the past
but not not now age I'd be like oh it's
since Todd like Todd
came in perfect timing for me but like
the guy I was seeing before Todd was
doing that to me so hard and that like I
don't know if he was doing it at me or
whatever but I was like activated I
remember being like I'm gonna I feel
sick like I felt like sick from it yeah
I was like I'm gonna die it's so funny I
wanted to talk about this but I today I
was thinking about it because I feel
like we talk about our exes a lot on
here and I want to be careful to be like
everything that's happened with my exes
has been me going through something and
other people are there kind of like
showing them to me it's like I can call
them all [__] if I want but I don't
think they're all [__] at all you
know it's just like what was it about me
that let myself be in that but with the
last guy I remember like I it was like a
what happened was I was staying at my
friend's house one of my best friends
who's letting me crash at his house and
he was like can you use just one favor
for me can just watch my cat I was like
sure and then I [__] forgot about the
cat because I was at this guy's house
being like do you like me do you like me
do you like and I [__] my friend was
like did you feed my cat and I'm like oh
my God like I forgot about my friends it
was like there was no I was like got so
obsessed with like trying to get this
guy to like me and I didn't even know if
I liked him right I was just like I need
to get this answer because it's a
dopamine hit too yeah and I just felt so
bad and that's when I was like okay
there's like a wake-up call like a
living thing got abandoned by me no it's
I would like ditch my family I would
ditch anyone for when that one guy would
call and be ready for you and almost
like it's a PSA to all the young girly
pops watching like if a guy takes more
than 24 hours to get back to ever once
and there isn't it's not like some rare
random specific reason like that is such
a red flag to me I feel like in the
beginning sometimes guys are are more
loving but are trying to like
hold back because they don't want to
give you the ick by coming on too hard
in the beginning too though I feel like
at the beginning for me no any game no
it's like a real a mature adult will
interact with you well like not play a
game or pull back I just think that's so
I'd rather I know you don't I guess you
are right you have to do a dance in the
beginning
strong because you are like sometimes
you're just so into the person in the
beginning and you just don't want to
like but I saw this one thing about this
guy who would literally strategically
wait 24 hours after each message and
then respond and like he that that girls
went crazy for it and it's like that's
sick well these guys also there's like
all of these these things online about
how to get girls there's so many men
that aren't born charismatic they don't
they're not good looking they don't have
their Swag like so they're going they're
like I gotta figure out some way to like
get girls a lot of these it's not always
nefarious I don't think I think
sometimes it's just like an incel trying
to get his get out trying to be an out
sales cells get out
I don't know
um no but um remember the the guy the
pickup artist like that is somebody that
like people that I love like Gilbert
fully like that was like his Bible right
so you're like you should I should have
known when you had a feather in your top
hat but I'm just saying like like
imagine all the misinformation these
they're now men but these boys were
getting at that time of like play all
the games
and this is how you get the girl and I
just think that like nothing makes me
hornier than consistency and knowing
that I trust you with my body and that I
trust you with like no matter where
we're at even in the beginning like I
just need to know that you are gonna
call me the next day that we're gonna
talk that like nothing makes me hornier
I know I do like that I did I think I
had an advantage being allergic to
condoms and in college in my whole years
and my my heavily dating years because I
couldn't really be
like I couldn't really just be [__]
someone like I kind of had to be like
hey here's the situation like you can
either like we can be friends or we can
keep [__] but you can't be [__]
other people those guys did cheat on me
but
um those were that was like actual time
period I got cheated on but
um
but it was like kind of forcing me to be
like do you want to be like
exclusive with me right away
because I was like I can't be having
these yeah because my pH which is up in
my drone off by basically just about
anything so that one of the one of the
ways that I found out that a boyfriend
cheated on me was like I was such an a
rage and I was like look at my [__]
she's not well she has a cough like he
wouldn't believe he's like why are you
thinking I cheated on you I just came
back from a trip from San Francisco and
I was like you we need to sit down and
talk and he was like why I was like you
need to tell me why and he's like why
are you saying this eventually he fessed
up and of course yeah what did you have
um I just had a really um I had a
bacterial infection it wasn't like a
true STD
baby actually it wasn't even BV it was
like but there was a reaction I had a
reaction and it was you know what I mean
not at its best yeah but I remember like
like pulling my lips apart and be like
look oh my God like you bad vicious like
yeah and I was like if you don't tell me
right now like and this is before I even
I didn't know if it was an STD or not I
was like if you don't tell me right now
I'm gonna go to the doctor and have him
tell me
so he eventually had to fasten I hope
eventually the doctor told you too yeah
but he's like oh it's just like you know
your pH is thrown blah blah blah but
that happens when you know like yeah
yeah when someone is sleeping with
someone else and they're introducing
like a new like element in there but
yeah like that's uh that's a really it's
like even in poly relationships they
call it fluid bonding you have to like
tell someone you're well that's what I
was talking about they're going to be
putting each other's milk in each
other's junk you should just you got to
tell people well that's what my friend
went through because she had to do in
vitro and it's I guess apparently a lot
of women get miscarriages because of
this because on a molecular level they
reject their partners
like baby basically so they have to
extract like white blood cells from the
man they prepare it and then they inject
the woman with it and so I was like why
can't I do this even without wanting to
get pregnant with my partner today or
with whoever I date just so there's more
of like an attraction maybe or that my
[__] won't reject that's a good maybe
that's that's our trash Tuesday Venture
we should all do it with each other no
we should no we need less with her give
her take some out of her of course
uh I can't handle sitting between the
sexual tension but um I think it's
called like lymphocyte immunization
that's a great idea yeah so do that
although I do not need it right now like
I last night we were we were like at a
restaurant and I was just like staring
at Dave I was like you're so hot right
now he's like you must be ovulating and
I'm like you're right I think I'm like I
have my ovulation goggles on because I
was just like
they say egg white yeah and you see it
on the rim you're like wow I am thick
and creamy today
I'm hitting the rim of the penis yeah
the penile you never look down and
you're like what did we make what kind
of cake batter did we make oh my God
never yes of course yeah and then you
they're like oh suck it and you're like
I gotta chew
well I'm spitting or swallowing my own
okay
guys I saw this thing today have you
heard of like the lesbian Master Doc or
something there's something that's going
around but basically is it an STD it's a
common theme amongst women to say I feel
like I've heard all of us say this even
like I'm attracted to women but I
couldn't see myself with a woman and
basically this girl was pointing out
that the reason we feel that way is
because we were not raised to see
ourselves as women we're so raised to
like see us ourselves dating men like
that's what's been we need lesbian
Disney Princesses yes so I just thought
that was interesting that really rang
true for me this could be population
control this could be what we need we
don't we I think we need the don't they
say the population is going down we need
more popular allegedly depends we need
more again yeah Oh I thought like two
years ago isn't this capitalist daddy
saying that oh you're right [__] I no
they got you again they always give me
world population is going up I think uh
Western world population is going down
yeah the world we're all freezing our
eggs it'll happen just wait it out yeah
and also doing it really late
okay so basically this is what I'm
trying to get at I have felt relatively
straight my whole life I've even been
quote unquote diagnosed it's like Oh no
you're definitely a straight girl by
girls I am trying to you know have stuff
with right they're like no colella like
you're pretty like your body you're dry
but I'm really gonna power through it
and I this summer I am committed to
having a full because I've only required
women in the context of a threesome but
why are you powering through something
if you're naturally not I think no
because I think by the time yeah that's
what she's saying like we've been maybe
programmed and I want to maybe fully get
there with just a woman without a man in
the room have full week of sex with a
girl that I that I find attractive and
see if I can feel that friend though
second knuckles in me I went
it wasn't like after all of it I went
but see you finally got there right I I
have I haven't been that far with just
the woman yeah it's always been a man
but I told you what she did to kind of
like plant the Seas where she was like
she was like well don't you think and
it's kind of what you're saying so this
could be all a ploy
there's one lesbian on tick that's
trying to [__] all of you guys well I
believe in this this Ring's really true
I think but she her thought was her
exposure her line to me was like the
fact that you've never felt gay or
attracted to a woman don't you think
that's like
because of your internalized like
homophobia and I was like what she's
like don't you think the fact you
haven't even thought about it makes you
gay and I was like what that is some and
it was like I was like I do all right
put them in okay I think yeah I do think
you are sure you can I read guy though I
do feel like I read guests no no no you
give me a masculine I have testosterone
yeah but masculine how you present is
definite it has nothing to do with your
sexuality because like you like feeling
energy wise super straight to me yeah
I'm not trying to Dave is usually like
he's usually so sensitive to any of
those
Dave is usually so sensitive to like any
joking about me being you know poor guy
it's like not fully straight but I mean
the man that knows you the most that
takes it the most serious but then this
weekend he was like talking about like
you know how he may die one day before
me and I was like No And then he was
like well then you can finally go off
and do what you really want to do and
have be with a woman I was like oh he is
open to it I'm just gonna kill him first
you start making him smoothies
uh no but I do Envy you for having a
younger boyfriend because
like whenever the reality sets in that
Dave is older than me I like I freak out
well there are like parent replacement
basically too yeah I feel like I
remember when I was when I fell in love
with my my like crazy boyfriend where we
were like we were like our most
heightened get police called on us
relationship it's just so weird how
different I can be like I'm like what
are like [__] poser I am that I could
be that psycho in that relationship and
then just never at all would Todd it's
just like how I'm just absorbing these
guys personalities like what's wrong
with me no you're not absorbing you're
maybe reacting yeah like I've been in
situations where I'm like I never
thought that someone could bring this
ugly side out of me but they have it
takes two to tango exactly yeah like
it's so real that then you're just not
like that at all well that's why like I
have to feel like I have to be careful
with the way I talk about all these
people because well I want to be careful
about it because I really don't want to
be like placing blame or like whatever
you know maybe some girl's into that I
don't know
um but when I first like was really felt
like safe with him he's changed kind of
quick but when I first like fell in love
with him I remember the relief of it was
like oh I'm gonna have someone and he
was very like paternal to me like he was
really like kind of told me what to do
and and like dominated me and um yeah it
was okay
it wasn't it's not really my thing but
um I tried
no I just felt like honestly raped I was
just being raped for three years being
really like forced into things but there
were benefits to it because I learned a
lot about myself and also he wasn't
raping me but but it just wasn't I I
don't
it wasn't for me but what did you I felt
like I remember just like crying and
being like Oh my God someone's gonna be
there when my dad dies that's how I felt
that yeah
like it was really like I didn't even
like I had I'd been repressing that
feeling for so long that I was just like
that was like the big relief for me and
then having a younger boyfriend is like
he's gonna be around when everyone dies
he's gonna be here when I die yes do you
feel like that's because that partner
that you were with was almost like a
father figure replacement
kind of and I yeah he would yeah I'm
like he'll pick up whatever and not that
like Todd isn't it's just I'm not like
unhealthy like that anymore I've done
like a lot of work on myself where
sometimes I'll have dreams where Todd
and I break up and in the dream I have
healthy responses to it I'm like okay
like if this sucks this is the worst but
I'm gonna be okay you know like I even
in my dreams I'm like living it out wow
you're not that mad at him in the
morning my dreams are [__] me up
again and I feel like it's they're
sabotaging me over and over again I'm
starting to dream of people I would have
never thought about like in a romantic
or sexual way but what happens in the
dream is that you fall in love with this
random person
who's just in your life like an
ancillary figure like for instance fancy
like I could have sorry for married guy
and it's [__] I know he's going
through some stuff
what was your son's name
um what is it Richie okay let's suppose
Richie eyes you're that Richie right
Richie is just a guy helping out here
yeah so let's suppose I just met Richie
today he took our order for your order
for sweet green and tonight I dream
about Richie I'm not kidding you when I
say that tomorrow I am fully in love
with Richard yes and the whole week I am
trying to get over Richie I'm doing
everything in my power and if I see
Richie here I am not even looking at him
because my feelings are real I would
have this literally sorry in middle
school and in elementary school you
child and it would be like the guy that
there's no Vibes at all like you and
then suddenly you're like what I'm in
love with that kid like ew so it is so
powerful it's really [__] up it's
sabotaging my dreams are sabotaging me
and I think that that's it's been
happening so much and I wake up and I'm
like
why but jungian theory of Dreams is that
it's all every person in your dream is
an aspect of yourself and your own
personality so maybe it's a part of your
personality that you're falling in love
with maybe we represents something of
yeah of yourself I like everyone in your
dream is you that is such a relief for
me to hear so maybe I'm falling in love
with myself yeah there's something that
he like some sort of young part of
yourself that you see in him my
recurring dreams are so back in action
of like I have to go back to high school
because I didn't actually graduate and
then I'm like it's either I have that
one or which is so funny because like
literally who cares I know like that
would be gangster if we found out you
didn't have a high school red like you'd
be a hero she doesn't even have a high
school diploma and then I like I am like
in this position where I'm like begging
like no I really don't want to like I
trust me like I want to go to La like I
can just handle it and then but then
recently there's been a change in the
dream where I'm like maybe it wouldn't
be so bad to go back where it's kind of
weird I'm like what does this mean and
then the other big recurring one is like
waking up on the last days of high
school and like getting ready for school
on the last day and I'm like what is
that like why do I want one last chance
to like stunt and like put on a cute
outfit and like shower I always just had
such a different heights I was just
dodging jizz from teachers oh my God one
more day here oh my God
a recurring dreams that I have
um
I don't have like a full understanding
of like or maybe it's just based on like
fear right my recurring dream is that
I'm behind the blocks and I'm about
behind in a swimming pool I'm behind
Lane four and I'm about to swim my 200
fly everybody is expecting me to win
everyone knows this is my race but I'm
in my 38 year old body and I have not
swam a [__] lap of butterfly in like
15 however long but the pressure is on
and I'm trying to tell everyone hey guys
like I haven't trained but no one is
listening or believing me that dream I
get at least like twice a month and it's
freaking terrifying what do you think
that means do you think that comes from
like if you haven't swam lately and
you're like feeling like you need to get
up on it I have no idea well it's like
obviously you feel unprepared for
something or yeah sure people are
expecting things from you maybe you're
expecting things from yourself if you're
everyone you're the people also putting
the pressure on me
um you're the swim cap
I am everything my goggles I'm the I'm
the block I have the water my version of
that is sometimes I have dreams where
I don't remember my jokes oh I've had
that where I just don't remember any
joke and I'm just up there like oh yeah
where oh my God like before a big show I
will so have that dream where I'm up on
stage I'm just kind of like
uh like thinking I'm gonna improvise a
whole set and I'm like why did I do that
why
and then I wake up and I'm just it's so
scary but isn't even just Big Show such
a nightmare like yeah before a big show
it's like why are we still doing this to
ourselves we've been doing this for so
long well because like you know for
example like my Show's coming up in New
York or like if I'm headlining it if I
have to do like a long set like 45
minutes to an hour and I haven't in a
while I definitely will in my dreams be
like oh there's I I can't it's
impossible I think my first set at a on
a weekend I'm always so I'm like yeah
you just don't you haven't been there
you don't have like the muscle memory of
like yeah like I don't stand on the
stage yet I don't believe I'll be able
to do it and sometimes I will beforehand
like uh I've been not writing out
setlist because I'm like sometimes I
think I sabotage but sometimes I'm
trying to write a set list out and I'm
like
I get to like four jokes like what do I
have any more jokes
I'm like I do this every night like
where's the rest
where's the 55 other minutes like what
the hell is going on I can't believe I
wonder I if I'm everyone in my dreams
I'm like so in the last day of school
one I'm also my mom making me a turkey
sandwich in the morning yeah like that's
cute I guess I don't know
yet do you have other recurring ones
um
not really I used to have dreams in like
specific places and sometimes I'll have
a dream where I feel like I'm like oh
I'm here again and then I'm like I never
was I'll wake up like I wasn't there
I've been taking melatonin so I have I
don't know what's going on I see I'm not
having a normal Esther I came across a
poem that um really made me think of you
in so many ways because remember Annie
was like
you brace when someone lifts their hands
yeah you immediately brace yes and it's
not even because you've ever just like
we've just been hit a lot so we're like
yeah so it's she was like well we were
wondering like oh why is it that you
know you brace even though you've never
been hit and she was like oh it's
because you're small right and so I came
across this poem and it's about a spider
but it's called the crime of being small
and I was in tears like bawling I really
thought we were gonna be making fun of
her it is you're the spider you know how
you hate spiders no you hate spiders but
basically one of the lines in there it's
like I'm so sorry for scaring you but I
didn't know we got wreck in here she
must be yelled at I didn't know that
being seen would cost me my life you're
just so tiny and I think you should stop
hating spiders because kind of you're
like you're the spider overall you just
have a bunch of spiders in your house
now you're the small thing
it doesn't happen it happens just the
best of us because rodents and spiders
can kill us
you can kill them this is enough I you
can't
you can't be thinking about dying all
the time I'm I don't but when I see a
black widow in my yard I'm like this is
real like I need to protect my little
donut and my little Dave and me wait but
that's that poem does sound really good
that was basically the line was I'm
sorry for scaring you but I didn't know
being seen would cost me my life and
that is the line that made me cry really
sad really sad that she thought of you
how does it feel that someone read that
and thought of you it feels really good
you're the fact that someone thought of
me feels really I would beat her ass if
she said that about me that you're a
baby spider you're just a baby spider
just accept who you are okay I wanted to
ask you guys do you in your day-to-day
life I know Annie like you're very
chatty with like the DMV person the bank
teller you're just friendly and like
chatty yeah but like in in passing Donna
am I Rite Aid what's up girl
do you smile at strangers
I live in Venice so the strangers you
can't smile
it's crazy over there
and then you think someone's not and
then you smile and then they there's no
teeth you go oh
boy I almost
always if I'm like being conscious and
aware of smile at women
that's about it I don't know if it's for
reasons did you go like this to men
no I just probably looked down and like
I smile I smile at strangers all the
time but I think um
um I was reading this thing about
the reason that in America we smile at
strangers is because we live in a high
uncertainty culture yeah and so we
basically have to acknowledge like hey
I'm not a threat to you but I totally
feel that yeah because in Korea or in
Japan in certain Asian countries not the
Philippines Filipinos smile at like a
tree like we just all we're always
smiling but in certain Asian countries
like that's that that are already
considered extremely polite societies
they don't smile at each other like at
all it's not considered like a polite
thing to do
because they have a more
um I guess certain culture they know
it's not like over here like we really
are afraid of a lot of things so you
kind of have to soften like your
surrounding you smile I'm not a threat
it's true and I've noticed like guys
they do the nod at each other a lot it's
which is almost like their version of a
smile I like the nod but I feel like
it's a girl the nod is kind of it's
almost like let's go I'm gonna give you
a hand job in this yeah you can't it's
always outside it's like I just feel
like guys are just like and I I could be
wrong I'm not a guy but I feel like guys
are just always oh they're looking at
every woman going like what I [__] her
and not all guys but like majority of
guys
like would I [__] her would she [__] me
like no matter what you can't smile I
it's like but in New York I had to like
squash my friendliness because it's
really looked down upon in New York and
if you're friendly like if you're going
to get a bagel at the bodega and you are
like how are you like people be like
shut up [__] like we're trying to go
it's like rude to be polite because it
takes more time you know yeah like even
people we're like boom boom which I
understand like holding doors open in
Korea Japan's not considered like polite
it's not over here you're like oh my God
what a nice young what if we get this
wrong way like go to Kareem or just
smacking people in the face with doors
although that does sound there is
something nice about that interaction
with strangers of like holding a door
like it's not that they don't hold doors
open it's just not considered polite
because it's almost the bass line
you know it's already a very polite
Society
um but over here we have to do things to
make our society more polite but I used
to date a guy that hated that I smiled
at people he's he just it drove him
absolutely nuts he was like you're
sending a message I'm like to who
to that you know decrepit 80 year old
man like who am I sending he's like yeah
I just don't like that you do that like
you just you know you're always and I'm
like dude like you got to work on your
[__] but now I'm thinking after what you
said Annie like maybe maybe he's on to
something maybe like dudes are kind of
calculating that going through the list
can I [__] her will she [__] me how do I
get her back I might be wrong but no I
definitely think there's a truth to that
yeah it's totally like a will she [__]
me thing I mean I've talked about this
before like there is like our peers who
I've like hung out with the comedy clubs
had like great conversations with where
I'm like oh my God like you're my peer
we're talking and then I hear like weeks
later that person said like I could [__]
her and I'm like
because we chatted what is going on yeah
what is this I know and then it's like
so I was I supposed to be a [__] the
whole time that was what I was supposed
to be doing to you yeah I think what
killed me not wanting to smile anymore
is dudes telling me to smile more yeah
like we're saying because like I kind of
have like a [__] face
um
total I have an RBF like a resting [__]
face since the day I was born so I've
always been told like why do you look so
angry why do you like that I'm like so I
maybe a part of me is always trying to
like compensate for that but then when
they're like you should smile more I'm
like that's it's just annoying it's like
I don't want to be smart like why do I
need to smile right now yeah
it's almost like it's so ridiculous I
can't even
justify that with the reaction it's like
telling someone to smile more it's like
are you Santa Claus like why why yeah
what am I getting out of this that's it
are we having a no smile summer then yes
okay no smells I'll try but I smile a
lot
you're just real nice to strangers but I
don't know if you're necessarily Like
Pat you know
I just realized something I totally
forgot when I'm with my guy friends I'm
so much more friendly and smiley and
interactive and I realize that after
like a while I was like oh it's because
I feel like safe and secure you know and
I feel social
I do think there is something to like
when you're just a girl on your own even
though I would love for this to be this
like fun when I read where I'm happy and
friendly and it's like it's just not
really when I make money
like if I have a good weekend I call
myself Annie bonus Letterman I'm I'm
twirling in the streets I'm so nice to
everyone I'm like hello there's like
birds
got new shoes on I'm like what's up
you guys I forgot to tell you breaking
news okay so you know how a couple weeks
ago I was talking about someone in my
life who I wasn't maybe approving of
their dating situation and I really
wanted to intervene and be like this
isn't this and this and poke and you
know prod and whatever and show them how
you know how right I am well I backed
off
and literally yesterday in a
conversation she said all the things I
was dreaming of her to say she was like
I'm mad at this person that they would
do this to me blah blah blah she just it
happened I let go yeah and instead of
pushing the narrative at her she found
it on her own and I am like beaming I'm
so happy I feel bad for her but it's
like yeah yes and you know what your
move is right when she tells you all of
this stuff is to not pile on it's sit
back because then she'll want to defend
him right right so what you do is like
oh [__] okay oh tell me more and just
keep pulling it out of her so she is
telling it to you the moment you pile on
back she's gonna are you sure though
because when when I broke up with that
one guy and then my sister-in-law was
like we were all so I was like oh she
was like so happy and I was like oh were
you worried about me and she was like
every day all this every day that made
me feel so good I was like oh my God
okay it was so validating I was like I
could never go back to this person I was
done already though yeah but that's not
a pylon like a pylon is a [__] well
they always get back together I told the
girl she was like my yeah my boyfriend
she this was very recent she was like my
boyfriend he's he's he yelled I think he
might have this or that she was like
diagnosing him and stuff I was like well
and I was like smart enough to go when
you're ready to talk [__] I'm ready
because I already was like who is this
[__] guy I wasn't that close to
friends with her but I was like who's
this guy literally marrying him now I'm
like that's what I'm saying that's why
I would have been
so [__] if I'd said stuff certainly
that this friend is really like done
with this guy it feels good it feels
really good to me like I and I didn't
quite pile on but I didn't I was like I
think out my my main reaction was like
I'm really glad to hear you say all this
like yes like this is great you should
be angry like and all that where I I
wanted to I didn't know what words quite
were right to use to get more because
it's out aside from just saying like
more more
um you should send her that extreme song
More Than Words great song
um it's good though because doesn't it
feel it's like there is I think such a
healthy thing about letting people have
their own experience you don't want to
steal people's like experiences from
that it doesn't work anyway but you like
it's so much better when people come to
it themselves and yeah you're not gonna
be like he's great or anything yeah you
know what 90s song still makes me feel
my feels because you said extreme
uh every [__] Mr big uh to be with
you is that song Still I don't know that
at all you guys I I've said this on here
before and it's it's still true
Whole Foods plays the best 90s music
it's always like oh all grocery stores
not just it's like crazy Chapman I'm
like I'm like in a fast car I'm like
okay I'm at a window I've come to a
window I have this theory that whoever
is making the playlist for all of the
grocery stores all the Safeway selects
is a freaking Mastermind and it isn't
some random occurrence that every time
you're in a grocery store there's at
least one song that hits you so deep
that puts you back in a state of pure
Nostalgia and you're like looking at
fruit and you're like I feel weird you
know but but the Whole Foods does every
song every song is on Todd and I were
like
banana breakfast at Tiffany or whatever
that song is we were like going crazy
yeah this girl was laughing at us
because we're like singing to each other
I mean we're like going nuts wasn't that
their only hit I have don't even know
the name of the band oh I I think it
wrote one hit wonder yeah
it was around like 90s yeah 90s yeah oh
my God it's just so fun and Todd I don't
know why he knows everything I know what
I think it's because his parents are
very close to my age we how are you and
his parents no his parents are like 16
years older than me but he's 11 yeah but
they're but they're Asian so like Asians
hang on to the classics harder his
parents are in their late 50s and I'm
turning 40.
Dave is 45 so Dave is peers with Todd's
parents no he's 10 years 11 years
younger
well you know my grandma is 82 and my
dad is 80. yeah it's so weird I know
well Mark Maron went on stage and he was
like my dad just turned 84. I was like
I went on stage after Mike is anyone
else surprised that I have the same age
I've had Mark's dad would be a hundred
years older than my mother I mean not
not too um oh yeah one-up you oh yeah
there we go let's do it hit us but my
dad was older than my grandpa
that's why a lot not just one or two
this is why she was hooking up with her
step brother do you understand it was a
confusing family Dynamic has anyone
brought like come to you because you
know like we're talking about stuff and
then people be like oh yeah I relate to
that me too has anyone come to you been
as a step yes uh you know who my twin
flame is
I found my twin flame and I did a family
where you have to try no I found her at
Esther's house
she's my twin flame she is not she is my
twin she's definitely not yours she
she's my imaginary friend
she is your imaginary friend she's my
imaginary friend but Rumi Neely and I
our lives are so parallel yeah
everything from the way we were brought
up our fathers like it's almost shocking
yeah everything that comes out of her
mouth is something that I live through
and
um it's kind of amazing right yeah you
guys are so similar it is like it's kind
of funny that's so sad no they're my
dolls I love that roomy's an actual doll
though oh my God I love her I'm like how
much more gorgeous can someone be and
she's so tall and just she is my
imaginary friend I made her up you
really didn't she's so she's Bonnie
she's my she's do you remember Drop Dead
Fred I love drop dead friends it's my
top five favorite movies have you seen
it recently is it still good
um it's not great but it doesn't matter
because Once you turn it on you you're
back but is there like black face in it
or anything you know like every movie
like watch a child maybe like oh they
were just like
and remember it was like Phoebe Cates
right yeah and Phoebe Cates is half
Filipina oh is she okay so that was I
don't know if she's happy she's part
Filipina so that was like a big thing
for me like and she's still married to
Kevin Klein which is so great it's so
cute that's another one of my favorite
movies no French kiss
[Laughter]
with Meg Ryan yes oh that was such a
great movie yeah I always liked Kevin
Klein
um so I got some questions for us I went
on our little Instagram and I got some
pretty interesting questions okay some
more advice summer you know 99 are [__]
married kills yeah exactly
um so this guy is asking should I tell a
girl that I'm not very experienced
before we hook up or just go for it
which I think is a really good question
it depends what kind of girl because if
it's me I love honesty and I like I'm
such a
I love Virgie like I love an
inexperienced boy like when I was in
high school I only because I was so
afraid of sdds I only had sex with
virgins I asked her too
also what are if what if this is STDs
what's just STDs no quotes I because
that's cities are [__] cool now yeah
oh also they're called like in my mouth
they're called that they didn't used to
be called like VD yeah real disease no
but one of my favorite role plays
um characters with Bobby he's a virgin
Brandon
he's a 50 year old man who's never had
sex and he's really shy funny to role
play he's the exact age
[Laughter]
your age he's never had sex and he's
just really shy you wouldn't want to
take like a old virgins I don't care I
just love virgins
[Applause]
it so sounds good it sounds you sound
like a 911 hijacker
[Laughter]
for this look when I say virgin I'm not
thinking of young boys I'm thinking of
you made it very clear
so this is something when a guy says hey
I'm nervous or inexperienced like come
to Mommy everything rename the show I'm
getting so hot what if we renamed the
show imagine if a guy said that
[Laughter]
it's just a hole every episode is just
imagine if a guy said that Lou you don't
have to imagine because they say it all
the time
but is this a terrible thing
I I wouldn't mind at all no I see that I
used to like that could be hot if you
like the guy and they're an experience
are you kidding that's hot because you
you can mold them into whatever you need
them to be but I know it's so much
hotter though what when you think a guy
isn't gonna know yes and then he knows
there was this kid I hooked up with
years ago
he was like uh he was at the coffee shop
which is my coffee shop guy oh my God
and he was just so young and so like he
was from Michigan does that explain it
yeah no yeah you know just like oh and
um I might ruin the story by saying a
young George Kimmel but it probably was
not a judge Gumball I promise did you
not think that fancy I thought that yeah
um I think I killed my own boner just
saying that honestly but he but that
would be surprising too wouldn't it
probably would be let's just say I've
never had one of those office dreams
with George I've been having
I've never had to avert my eyes from
George
but he was really a very talented young
man he was really cute I see I like that
and he was like a PA at the time so he
would like he would be like I have my
work truck he'd be like near the comedy
club he's like come out and we'd like
hook up in the truck it was cute when
it's unsuspecting but then I would go
back in because I was so used to like
being friends with guys and like male
Comics I'd be like oh yeah this kid just
fingered me in his car and they're like
oh I'm like you guys say stuff like this
to me you I just broke down way too hard
they're like ew like oh yeah you know
what I need to stop doing I think it was
cool I thought we were gonna pound with
my guy friends wait this is actually a
real problem of having like with people
that I'm dating
um I talk like I'm in I'm on the show I
[__] this
[__] this you know [__] in the ass
like so [__] me yeah and it's honestly
probably such a turn off but I forget
that regular people outside of you guys
[Laughter]
they don't take to that like I forget
that you can't talk to people like that
for me
wait but Esther you wouldn't what would
you do like would you want a guy to tell
you or not tell you it's so tricky
because one time like in college there
was this guy that I was hanging out with
and I remember he told me he was a
virgin and it did kind of freak me out
but only because I really Associated
that with being religious and I'm very
anti-religion because I'm the devil
um but like that was and I just don't
think there was a vibe there so I think
that is like a specific incident but
when when I hear you kind of like when I
hear you say it but like a guy being
like just so you know I'm not that
experienced there is something exciting
there of like well great he's not some
like [__] boy you know and like you said
like you couldn't train them like I
believe that you can have good sex if
you like a person it's good sex like you
will make it good you you will find your
ways to make it good I with no pillow is
so weird me with a hoisted up pillow too
though it's like the pillow it's like I
I'm in a fight I'm wrestling right now
I'm on the show glow I love that show I
actually I'm a little icked out Annie by
the one that you like where a guy where
you don't think he's gonna have
experience and then does
I'm like
ew I'm like why I don't know there's
something about that that I wouldn't
want I don't know why
um I am I agree with Annie there's
almost just like oh my God I was so
proud of him I was like my God no
because then that's like why you're
playing this like shy little boy no he
is shy he just is shy but also good in
bed
he's just he's not tricking no I came to
him let's be real
he was like my I think I was I can't
remember I had a really good line for
him I can't remember what it was oh I
had I used to have cards that said like
little those little MOO cards that I
used to put I had I would say um follow
me on Twitter
oh no I would go I think you're hot but
really I just want you to follow me on
Twitter and then I was like you don't
need to follow me on Twitter I just had
it gave it to him whatever
he was cute but um
I have a question for you guys uh are
you thinking about this
guy hypothetical guy that uh as it's
Andres younger is he a younger person
and you guys are older or are you guys
same age you know what this guy yeah
this guy 20. oh no no no I say I I'm not
there's like 5 30. we know when I'm
answering these questions about virgins
like I could never like
that was really awful of you I killed
every boner in this room I realized that
now no I'm just asking because if this
guy is whatever in high school and wants
you know I feel like very different than
anything I think okay so this is what I
think I think if you're gonna be like
whatever's gonna make you less nervous
like if you're if you like being
vulnerable and open it's really about
what you want it's really not about like
if she doesn't like what you do or
doesn't like you being honest that's not
like the person that you're gonna
continue with anyway so it's like if
you're gonna be fumbly and nervous and
if you're inexperienced or an experience
you can't pretend to not be an
experience yeah but everything guys have
always heard is like you have to be so
confident because that's yes but if
you're not confident how are you going
to be confident do you know what I mean
maybe if sometimes telling the truth
makes you more confident I mean look if
you can fake being confident fake being
confident for sure because what's the
difference between being confident and
faking being confident you can be
confident I would come in with a game
plan I would try and learn up the best
that I can yeah read she comes first
like making sure yeah just read she
comes for a section here I will say to
this guy like
the one thing that I love is when dudes
ask me like how I like it because it's
like it doesn't matter how experienced
you are this is a completely different
body than the last girl you were with so
it's like
my friend I won't say his name
um but he was basically like when I'm
with a girl I'm her remote control
I'm sorry she is my remote control
like I do whatever she wants and I tell
her that like you're my remote control
tell me what you like and I'll do it and
I'm like that is so hot like I love that
so I think experience or not you can do
a lot of things wrong so just be very
attentive to like the girl also
communicating which can be so hard it
can be hard it can be so hard so hard to
say what you want like sometimes I like
I wouldn't even know I was just like uh
basically a sock for a decade yeah like
so I'm like what I want I don't know
what I want no but now it's like
communication is like I'm so good at it
that and it's never awkward or weird
where I'm like hey can you sit up and
can you do this instead can you do a
setup you're like
don't lay flat on top of me and finger
me sit up like I want you know it's uh
we're both thinking about that uh
sit up aren't we so we can't this it up
no I'm just imagining like he's like
sitting up like
the ways
um you know what I'm lying on you while
he's that's kind of hot I don't like a
next two fingering no because you're not
doing you don't have full access full
range of motion like you're just not
doing it to the best he's just looking
at your face what does he look like yeah
exactly
Annie you can't do it when he's laying
flat on top of me trying a great lesbian
honestly I love lesbian dreams sometimes
where I'm crushing it it's like I'm a
guy in it and I'm like I am like the man
I do feel like I could just woo a [__]
that's why I'm like you really would I
think yeah I think you probably would
many and like not know about the shame
this is a crying shame
I could I know because I know what I
like so I'm like yeah I could do it to a
girl um there's like I think that's just
the frustration I've had with guys I've
been dating where it's like you can't
there's certain things you can't
communicate like
um the lean you know that lean in where
it's like you have to lean in you have
to like it's like you have to make me
feel at the same time like safe and
scared and small yeah but it's like how
do you explain that to someone and then
if they you tell it to them and then
they do it people just have it though
but it's hard I know it feels impossible
I know guys get all mad when girls are
like and they have to do this and that
yeah and like sometimes I'm like I want
a guy who cries but not like all the
time
they can't just like have to carry
tissues around for him you know you guys
know that J Cole song wet dreams no but
it's like it basically captures
perfectly the first time like wait what
a guy what if fancy was listening to
that on the way in he was like that's
actually the song I was listening to wet
dream
um
he talks about just being really
inexperienced when he's younger and
really wanting to like perform well and
both him and the girl pretending like
they had done it before but then
ultimately at the end of the song they
really were just like they had both not
done it before but they had put so much
pressure on themselves so it's a really
sweet song full of Dreams the guy I lost
my virginity who was not a virgin so
that wouldn't I would never have that
experience same
um not weird I feel like that's
something to think about too when you're
losing your virginity like you wanna if
you ever want the experience of losing
virginity with someone can I tell you
something only one shot no I was so
scarred by the guy I lost one or Hyman's
back up Todd might be convergence again
the first the first guy that I ever had
sex with was a virgin and um it was
really a terrible experience for me I
didn't feel ready I thought that oh we
were both doing this for the first time
so maybe it might feel a little bit
hated it then have sex for another like
year and a half yeah and I broke up with
immediately after I was like oh I did
not like that so it's not always great I
don't know it's a loose lose I think I
didn't mind that the personalities had
done it like they knew what they were
doing oh really I'm like that's better I
don't know oh my God you probably came
when you lost her virginity ew why would
you even say that sweet just sexually
healthy and it's annoying no I mean I
was but I didn't go go imagine coming
the first time you ever have sex like is
that a thing for girls ever I don't know
but I don't know I looked like it in the
notebook but I'm not sure
ugh the way movies just totally tricked
us
yeah right I was like sex was so bad for
so long like it was so painful and so
uncomfortable for so long when I was
young yeah maybe you had vaginous Miss
what's up like it really was really
tight well I am constantly in a clench
on on that note
clench our way out of here this week
yeah you guys thank you for being here
this for this random sexual I know I
literally relationship talk I was
thinking I was like I wanna I just want
to stop talking about X's it's like I
don't care it's like full X episode I'm
sorry but that's what we have for our
life experience your life experience I
know everyone relates to it really well
I was thinking though on the way over to
like the there were like breakup songs I
was like I used to love breakup songs
and now I'm in love so I just like songs
about how people love each other oh I
still love breakups I do too I don't
they don't slap for me anymore really
oh I love them I'm able to put myself in
that mode of desperation even if I'm not
desperate or sad Todd will play songs
for me and like he'll be like this is my
song for you like that's like what I'm
into 311 Amber no he played uh Hozier
um
something about talking to strangers or
something I can't remember what it is
I'll find out for next episode
um you guys thank you for listening and
we will see you click the notification
Bell yes click the notification Bell
thank you so much and we'll see you next
week with a brand new episode
[Music]
oh
wow